I ran for a couple years how are you
fine thank you how are you I hear my
books arrived just today that's right
you know it was here before we didn't
get they walked in this morning and
handed it to know I was there right
today they arrived I saw the mail yeah
they were sent immediately yeah well is
it said rush on it but it was on my desk
this morning
so but I get it I mean I understand what
the book in the book luckily you've
created a brand yes so that I kind of
understand resistance is futile yes it's
and now the strong tightening left lost
its collective mind people know where
you're coming from
yeah and boy are we seeing this week I
didn't I I can't believe this woman this
professor at a marginal College
apparently has a veto over at any
Supreme Court nominees I do you think
she's credible or no oh good grief now a
recovered memory 30 years later and then
oh she's got to testify she's got to
testify lead editorial in New York time
she's got to testify uh no I don't think
I want to go under oath okay how about
we send you know Grassley you suggest an
hour they're going to send staffers out
to Palo Alto to politely and gently
interview her just to get her under oath
she hasn't agreed to that yet so she
won't go under oath but she does want to
talk about it like she wants to test the
fly but she won't do it under oath oh
she doesn't want to testify at all oh
she doesn't know that's under oath
originally he wants to hold a big press
conference start weeping so that the
media can kind of join in didn't she
want to be anonymous at first oh yeah
just like Anita Hill yeah yeah I see
what out didn't eat a hill I believe it
was someone on senator Metzenbaum staff
gave it to Nina Totenberg okay and then
she mentioned her name yes and oh look
at how a Nita Hill has suffered that
among the BS lines were getting from the
media and this is what drives me crazy
oh it was so brave for this woman to
come forward Oh give me a break she'll
upgrade from some marginal college in in
Palo Alto should be teaching at a
fabulous College and look at look up a
neat Hill's Wikipedia page her entire
life since accusing Clarence Thomas has
been
awards fellowships here
could you write an op-ed for the New
York Times will he be our speaker will
you be our honored woman of the world of
the year no nobody would rather be say
judge Cavanaugh right now compared to
his his accuser who refuses to back this
up and she didn't I mean by her own
admission she didn't tell anyone for 30
years she suddenly remembered when
Cavanaugh was back in the news as a
likely Supreme Court nominee better than
for Mitt Romney in a therapy session so
we're supposed to believe a recovered
memory I think is that what it was it
wasn't that she just didn't say anything
was that she didn't remember until I
think she says she didn't remember
that's a little weird I could understand
if somebody says well I never said
anything because I wanted to erase the
memory but it was traumatic seeing this
guy on TV can't believe that if it was
really so effing traumatic and by the
way what she's describing I don't even
want to get into this cuz it never
happened can we pull girls and see how
many this has happened to your jumped
your groped by by a drunken boy in high
school oh my gosh if this is what the
standard is no and and this is coming
from the same people who have been
telling us it's going to be Handmaid's
Tale if if judge Roberts is is confirmed
at the Supreme Court of course we saw we
see the terror that Clarence Thomas
unleashed for the last 30 years he's
issued conservative ruling so they tried
to warn us jail so they asked you to you
said that in one interview recently that
you have lost a lot of liberal friends
which it really is interesting how
people get like become fragile I don't
care what the politics of my friends at
all but but I guess a lot of people go
yeah I don't know I just I have a
summation of an everyday we use did you
miss yes there's in the observer I lost
yeah I saw the headline and I didn't
read it which is weird because he's a
smart guy and we had an interview and I
guess he thought that would be a catchy
headline let me tell you what it said in
a recent interview in the observer and
she discussed missing her liberal
friends since Trump took office and this
is in quotes one of the things I miss
now in the Trump era is that I used to
have a lot of liberal friends we'd have
big dinner parties and we debate and it
was fun and we'd go out I still have
some liberal friends I can talk to but a
lot of them I can't I miss some of my
friends
um yeah that's true but that's not that
I lost a lot of liberal friends what I
miss is going to dinner parties and
arguing no I mean of the actual friends
I have lost one never Trumper and he
just lost his mind oh really
yeah and the good thing is I was always
the one insisting come with us on ski
trips and parties and dinner parties and
going to the beach and all the rest of
my friends hated him hated him with the
hot hot hate of a thousand suns and I
was always the one to go come on he's
funny he's funny yeah okay nobody likes
his his cooking he can be a little
obnoxious but he's fun come on and
suddenly he is the one who just it was
when when when Cruz dropped out mmm
he said I no longer I no longer want to
receive your missives referring to
emails and I thought okay well that's
one
now we all get together there's no
problem no one will say do you have to
keep inviting this guy but he's gone
just full-on nevertrump when you argue
with people even friend are you are you
do you ever go like alright you know
what that's a good point I didn't think
of it yeah okay
Oh totally especially with people that
you know cuz I have a lot of smart
friends and often I mean this that was
also what I really liked about college
speeches at the lesser schools the main
question was you're an ugly fascist they
are quick to the mic they got to get
that out because that's an important
question they got me on the right
feelings you know I got to see I got to
see an Ann Coulter uh I got to see an
Ann Coulter college speech when I was in
college where it's Syracuse oh it was a
debate with Janet Reno right no it was
like 2003 years and you were there and
you were giving a speech and I don't
even I don't it wasn't even anything
specific in the talk but just mid talk
there was a girl who was in one of the
back rows she just stood up she shouted
Nazi at you and then she marched out and
you chuckled and went along with the
speech
as if nothing it happening you don't see
particularly that's probably what annoys
them the most is that you're just unfair
I talked about your reach that we did
that and I like Moshe kasher and we did
his show together
he's Valeri who's the wind drop the
other guy Lucien Lucien
yes Lucien and it was fun to watch the
entire audience not agree with you and
you truly didn't give a [ __ ] it was
enjoyable to watch the girls and buckle
the world it shouted Nazi and was so
much more emotionally distressed by
degrees of degrees in degrees than Anna
in any way shape if you can see it right
now you've never seen a happier person
they haven't come up with a better
argument since you know I went back to
Syracuse it must have been within four
years and I debated Giannino so I go out
with the College Republicans afterwards
um I usually have dinner with them and
there's this one kid who keeps he's
quite perky about it B keeps telling me
all the crazy things they're saying at
like the Green Party meetings and at
some way and they were crazy things but
I said what are you like a mole at these
meetings
and he said no no I used to be a member
and then I saw you give a speech here a
few years ago and I came to protest but
I get everything you were saying I kept
saying yeah I agree with that
oh no it's probably the Nazis must have
been the Nazi speech so there is a good
reason for liberals to prevent me from
speaking I'll be the only conservative
bill here in four years all I know is
Nazi don't listen to her not so you
don't listen to her so if they listen to
me a lot of kids will change the wrongs
but I was gonna say about changing my
mind I mean some of the college kids are
really smart and they will ask good
questions
what's a tough one you've been asked or
one that made you go like huh it's hard
for me to well it's been some time since
I'm gonna given a college speech you're
not allowed well now I I started I
started a a an LLC with my liberal
friend Mickey cows because he's not
insane okay we do agree on immigration
we disagree on every single other thing
under the Sun and I thought now that
these college kids are going nuts and
you know they'll burn the campus down
she's conservative she shows up
how start why they're smashing Starbucks
windows though I kind of approve of that
and and so we were like it to be
debating team so that way they'll have
both a liberal and a conserving right
and if the concern it's usually the
conservative group that's gonna sponsor
a debate and they'll be happy because
when we get around to immigration I mean
for different reasons and different
angles what we both take the same
position on immigration but I think
that's the only way I'm gonna be able to
sneak into college campuses now or I'm
say it's like David Duke is showing up
you ought to see the police force that
has to would you speak at Berkeley cuz I
remember there's a big problem I think
for Ben Shapiro there was for Milo there
was and for you and it's and for you
there was a huge did you actually be
there man you mentioned that because I'm
kind of annoyed that liberals have
gotten full credit for I mean everyone
said come on you little brats to get the
gals on the view who supported me
President Obama brought it up yes that's
right on his own
nobody even specifically said hey what
do you think about again Coulter not
speaking at Berkeley you and teachers
brought up this is outrageous of course
you should allow Ann Coulter to speak at
Berkeley so liberals across the board
get credit for saying Ann Coulter should
speak at Berkeley no she has not and I
did I mean you don't want to be I don't
really care as little brats don't want
to hear my pearls of wisdom but I do
think it's an important principle for
free speech so I gotta tell you I spent
the last six months people I know went
to Berkeley or still have affiliations
at Berkeley I said could you tell them
they ought to bring me in to speak I
will wait discount my speech I'm not
giving it free because then it's just
sure I look like an idiot right
demanding to speak at Berkeley but I
really think for the principle of it I
need to speak that yeah yeah I mean I
think that that's the one thing that the
the Trump era has done it has really
destroyed conversation in the sense that
since Trump was elected I think when he
was running you might still be able to
have a conversation he was gonna lose
but literally since election night not
even when he was in office but since
election night the idea of any sort of
you don't even have to be a trump
supporter a Republican Democrat
conversation right just doesn't it can't
having a very very rare yeah and it's
really too bad because I think we can
agree on a lot of things I mean the good
thing about Trump is she really talked
about not caring he's really smashing
political correctness and that I think
is good he's given a voice to the
working-class people who haven't voted
for 30 years he wasn't really keeping
his promises he's smashing I think he's
exposing the media in a way they've
never been exposed I mean I always
thought they were lying swine but I
think the average person didn't realize
how how utterly partisan they are just
down the line and they become a little
bit more partisan you sense much you
know it's like it's like they become
exposed yeah yeah totally no they're not
even trying to hide it or pretend to
give both sides anymore so all of that's
good but the bad thing is it's forcing
the never Trump errs and the and the
Democratic Party and the media into
positions if they've never held before
and that I think aren't good I mean
that's what a lot of resistance as
futile is about because I watch MSNBC
all day I'm a big hate watcher you start
to notice it wait a second my entire
life you guys loved Russia with the
gulags you loved it with Stalin and the
show trials and when they're murdering
millions of people well we have to have
a mature relationship with the rest of
the world and the remember sting the
Russians love their children too and dr.
Zeus had a book now okay we're Reagan
won the Cold War it's over yeah it's
over they're not shooting down our
planes there no gulags there no Stalin
show child and now it's just like a
normally corrupt country I wouldn't live
there I wouldn't want to live in a lot
of places and according to these exact
same people who told me that Stalin was
a little pussycat now it's the most
psychotically evil governments in the
world I kind of feel you know you bring
up MSNBC is like the hate watch Network
and I kind of feel because I try to
watch like everything and figure out
what's going on and like I watched CNN
more often now than ever just to kind of
observe and I still think like I think
Erin Burnett still kind of has a head on
her shoulders you're right right but I
watched like this the primetime shows
after her and like the
Anderson Cooper's and the Don lemons and
stuff and I feel like they've gone so
nuts the Cuomo's they've gone so crazy
that MSNBC actually starts to feel like
middle ground which is like the anti
position and it used to be right
no I've noticed that I mean there it's
it's very close it's like the difference
in being thrown from the 14th floor or
the roof but yes yes
like what Anderson Cooper's do an
eight-minute monologues about Donald
Trump Jr's Instagram like this is just a
guy who's hurt like this is just a guy
he got his feelings hurt because that
was pointed out yeah like and it's like
okay I'll watch that I like you know
watch it guys have their feelings hurt
and talked about it but we have to this
is what this is now this is a guy and on
lemons kind of done the same thing where
he'll like clearly present an opinion
right and be like this is what's
happening in the country and it's like
wait this is how you feel about what's
happening in the country yes that's the
same thing as described there there and
I love their there their typical
especially MSNBC which I do watch more
because I think in a way they're a
little crazier but I know what you're
talking about there's a search over
thinking well this will only be the 14th
floor not the roof oh my gosh it's the
Empire State Building but they're there
typical Republican needless to say I'm
100% banned across the board from I run
and I would love to go on I mean I think
why wouldn't they have you on like just
if they hate you want to just have you
on until I don't understand why they
don't try to beat you up innocent like
well I think their viewers they're like
college students they just don't even
want to hear it and so why you know take
the hit hit to the ratings you're gonna
get look viewer mail and why not just
keep making 7 million a year just going
you know going on coasting and oh this
isn't normal
what an original thought that is what do
you think of this whole a thought of
whenever there's a conservative speaker
whether it's banning or somebody they
just don't like think we don't want to
give them a platform like when did that
start to become the thing with a stage
you shut people up by saying we don't
want to give you a platform no that is
definitely Trump ii-era stuff we never
were like that before and the bad thing
about it is for from issues that I care
about the wall immigration trade deals
the things that average Americans have
just completely been left behind on the
Democratic Party at least used to
pretend to care about flyover people and
maybe you know it reached the point that
they decided they don't need them we're
just gonna go with the coast elites and
the identity politics and screw people
in Indiana but you know who it used to
be Jesse Jackson down at the border who
gets hurt by this unrestricted low wage
immigration both legal and illegal the
most well african-americans Hispanic
Americans all the people there claiming
to represent and it does seem like
weather I mean they can blame Trump I
don't but but because they've they've
lost their minds they're one half of the
country's position is what's Trump's
position on this oh that's awful and it
doesn't matter if it's something they
believed their entire lives on what's
Trump's position on this that means not
exactly your typical Republican right
he's not mr. Chris Jenni's he's married
to a model living in Trump Tower or not
they don't have to worry about daily
Bible readings but they they Trump has
just so caused them to lose their mind
that I think we can't work for things
together and you know maybe Trump I I
thought Trump should have had when he
first got to office have like an oval
office speech then to the nation say you
know I said a lot of wild things on the
campaign yeah but I think we can all
come together this is why we need a wall
it's it this is what 100 percent
responsible for the heroin epidemic more
people are dying of heroin and fentanyl
overdoses every year than died in the
entire course of the Vietnam War that is
because we don't have a wall on our
border we have we've been leaving behind
we've been taking care of Wall Street
we're taking care of the corporations we
have not been taking care of the
manufacturing base and the working class
in America for 30 years and I think
that's something we can all agree on so
I'm gonna send this bill over I I don't
think it would have worked but I kind of
wish he had done that right and who do
you think you said you thought Jared
Christian wrote the Appa do you really
think that or who would the other
possibility the op-ed in the New York
Times anonymous right from inside from a
high-ranking official in the White House
yeah right well my my position was when
it first came out it is either Jared and
why Jared because he's got to go back to
the Hamptons
but isn't the risk for him too great I
mean that's a family thing with a
billion dollars of state like he almost
even met whether or not the the society
a quote-unquote the society you think
that he likes her that he does like will
never probably take him back because
he's Trump's son-in-law right that's
almost too big a risk to take no I think
they'll take him back if he can go
around saying I'm the one who stops the
wall
don't worry if I stopped all that scary
stuff that you didn't want it was right
after Labor Day they were probably
feeling wistful for the Hamptons knowing
right after John McCain's funeral I
could be the John McCain and try now the
alternative is that it's just some you
know like assistant Commerce Secretary
somebody whose name we don't know who's
technically yeah but my argument was if
it's that kind of person who then would
come out of the closet get I mean all
over you saw a publisher saying
seven-figure advance
you've never wrote this immediately so a
you could or me Daniels has a book about
Donald Trump's penis like you get
anybody who's got willing to give out
information gets a book deal right you
could be set for life you could get a
nice fellowship at American Enterprise
Institute so I said what I mean people
know who it is he knows who he is the
name is gonna leak if it's that kind of
person and the name hasn't leaked hands
right it's Jared right the only way it
doesn't leak is if it's Jared or
somebody else high up like Jeff Sessions
or one of those guys I just love that
though because then Jared sitting there
like like there's no there's no winning
for Jared Kushner in this scenario
because if it's not him he's not gonna
say it is him but if he doesn't say it
is him then according to Ann Coulter
it's him yeah that's true though
eventually he's gonna have to tell the
Upper East Side and the Hamptons the
Hamptons are important yeah yeah now are
you allowing maybe a personal dislike
for Jared to influence your decision um
no I mean the weird thing is I actually
think he's a really nice guy I don't
think you should be in the White House
if my my father bought you know a real
estate company I wouldn't push everybody
out and say here let me run it are you
afraid of Trump on fine I like the fact
on Twitter you'll criticized Trump and
you're the only peep
he follows do you worry about him on
following you
I was I was terrified when I started to
get particularly testy with him and I
was out in fact with with a liberal New
York Times reporter and I said anyone
meaning there's some breaking it was
going me to check and I said I can't
check I can't check I think Trump is
gonna unfollow me after this one and he
said and I promise you he follows like
ten people if he unfollowed you it would
be popping up on my phone right now so
it occurred to me that maybe maybe it
would seem to he might have muted you
because I mean in heat contrary to what
people say he does listen to people I
think he knows I have his best interest
in mind though I know I know some of my
tweets sure like the border wall update
I keep giving every day but i suspended
it before the midterms I only go back
when I'm feeling really testy now as
soon as the midterms are over we are
going right back to that for the whole
update I know he gets tests you buy them
but he doesn't I mean why doesn't it
occur to him every time some people give
me advice and I follow it on let's see
Jared told me fire Comey they'll love it
back Luther strange in Alabama that's
what led to the Roy Moore thing but
because Trump backs the idiot
establishment candidate who's totally
against the Mogga Endemol there was a
great guy writing there's a congressman
wanting him back mo Brooks no Jared told
them you got to go with Mitch McConnell
but do you tax cuts it's always a total
disaster Oh Jared let's bring in half of
Goldman Sachs Gary Cohn he'll be great
scaramouche II I mean I like scaramouche
II but that didn't work out that well
you would think at some point for this
100% Jared okay okay he'd noticed but
Wow every time I take a Ann Coulter's
advice things go great do you think the
Jared Kushner wrote the the op-ed or do
you kind of all she's got a foot in his
back she and wants him out there she's
building him out of the White House and
you were trying to [ __ ] you're trying
to elect your slide your way right into
that position do you think Jared you
think Jared Kushner is happy knowing
that that the Donald listens to Ann
Coulter do you think Jared they're like
you pushing this agenda I mean we'd like
to want to another during the campaign
he wanted his father-in-law to win
because obviously that sure it's bad
good for him father yeah but like I say
this isn't like a personal anger or
animus he just doesn't know anything
about politics I see and that's why he
keeps making missteps he knows a lot
about a lot of things I again I wouldn't
think of say if my father bought a shoe
company okay Ivanka you're out okay yeah
we're gonna get them made in Malaysia
but and they don't make shoes in
Malaysia that's Jared in the White House
I see so do you think you'd be better in
the White House than Jill I don't want a
job this is not an Coulter buys a job
but would you like if they asked you for
your really better consult I just want I
would be better so I'm asking trumpet
fire every single person in the White
House he would wake up alone leave my
Twitter feed and just do it right I see
I see so you'd like to leave in the
White House from your Twitter account
well no also actually he wouldn't even
need to read my Twitter feed if he fired
everyone because I think Trump's
instincts are amazing oh my gosh is
political is it things good though
because a lot of the people he's hired
or a lot of the people around him are in
big trouble
so does that say anything about his
instincts not being great all these
people are now in trouble or I don't
hear about the trouble what I care about
is that they all hate the Mogga Genda
and I mean this was always you know
nobody's perfect and and the flaws with
Trump the great thing about Trump is his
amazing political instincts I mean the
Mexican rapists speech that should go
down in political rhetoric was the
greatest speech ever given he beats
Churchill with a rock okay that's after
after I guess it was the the pit was the
Paris attack in December right and he
comes out with a Muslim man what was so
brilliant about Trump is he not only had
good instincts for what the public
overwhelmingly wanted but it was always
something that the media would so hate
did he'd get lots of publicity for it
it's not like you know he drops the
Muslim ban and no one notices what about
after Charlottesville when he was like
ah there's bad on both sides let's not
like what I
Chapter three okay when I watch that bad
everything he said was perfect okay well
that's a per fact when I watched that
back I look at that and I'm like that's
literally one of the worst moments in
any president no it was one of his I
think it was his greatest moment as
president so far why because he wouldn't
give in to the to the browbeating of the
press
he has been totally proved right by
history I mean they just had the
anniversary of Charlottesville
there isn't a quote white supremacist in
sight and they're burning down
Charlottesville and Washington DC
beating up cops were you know just
hysterical anger I faced the ante for
Antipas I have for a decade now don't
tell me there's no violence on the left
side it almost always comes from the
left there and yes there were I'm sure
there were good people on that on the
anti facade but there were definitely
good people on the don't tear down our
monument side they've never heard of
this this showboat flamboyant Richard
Spencer he was a bit that was apparently
the problem that he was one of the
organizers they just think no this is
part of American history don't go around
tearing down monuments well since then
they've and this is in in Chapter three
of my book on Charlottesville the list
of monuments they're tearing down and
defacing you know Columba three um
Christopher Columbus statues here in New
York have been defaced ripped off one
was decapitated in Chicago hilariously
enough they defaced the statue of
Abraham Lincoln every single Confederate
I had no idea there were so many little
Confederate monuments all over just like
little plaques here do you think I'm
irritating though they can get rid of
them just go there they annoy me but do
you think that they can no I don't I
don't like their ways and look at this
some dick on a horse I'm like a mole
here I don't care about it you know you
can avert your eyes well I can avert my
eyes from hustler you can avert your
eyes there's no reason to bring Larry
Flynt's great work into this level like
these Confederate monuments are
monuments to aside that since they lost
their enemies to all of us in America
their treasonous people right no because
the North won so we're all the north now
well yes but for one thing I mean
they've been around for a hundred years
have been really been bothering people
all this time this is why Jim yes yes I
won't do certain gigs it has nothing to
do with the fact that no one shows up
anymore but what was so there were many
wonderful and valorous things about our
Civil War 600,000 white men died for the
principle that equality is equal every
country in the world has had slavery
some still do we're the only country who
went to war to redeem the principle that
all men are created equal
so it in in that way it's a great story
most of the Confederate soldiers they
were just poor they were southerners the
south is is our warrior class in America
I mean that is becoming less so as as as
southerners move around and northerners
moved to the south but I mean every I'm
fear saying this they'll change it all
of these it's interesting almost all of
our like military bases are named after
Confederate soldiers because they were
such stunning warriors meanwhile our
weaponry is named after after Indians
again why to honor them because they
were such great warriors which is why
drives me crazy when they change sports
teams names no we want to be called the
Apaches because we thought they were
cool and brave and strong they're not
being called you know they in New Canaan
cheerleaders I like I like I don't like
the Indian names but it's only because
they wouldn't do it to anybody else like
it's not because I'd say offend me
but they would never do it I mean
Redskins isn't exactly a tribe yeah
that's good you know they would come to
my or their valor but if another group
complained they would go like if you say
to be racist in the locker room they
[ __ ] but it's not very it's an honor
but a lot of the Indians don't see it
that way and they would not true it's a
lot of white liberals but every time
they pull Indians they love it but
you're saying like they wouldn't do a
team for like the Zulu warrior they they
wouldn't do it to another group but if
we don't watch the same porn I do
because you brought up Trump's instincts
Troy do you have the video of Trump
talking about the hurricane because this
is not
this is just I mean when we talk about
instincts and yeah let's get that TV on
because I'm not you're not sold on the
instincts I'm not sold on the instincts
because sometimes I feel like you know
like obviously we disagree on the
charlottesville and we're on chapter
three he wouldn't read it because I
didn't want to have the conversation
here I don't want to have a dialogue
yeah I don't want to be triggered okay
this is a this is the statement it's a
it's a video statement pre-recorded did
President Trump one did it give this he
put it out yesterday yes yesterday
afternoon it's about the Herick the
storm that hit the Carolina thank all of
the incredible men and women who have
done such a great job in helping with
Florence this is a tough hurricane one
of the wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water rarely have okay now
an experienced record plenty of time to
do another take
explain to me somebody who you say is it
like this great communicator
yes great interesting great instincts
okay the instinct to not only say the
wettest in terms of water and then leave
it in perfect as a matter of fact they
went to b-roll as he was saying show
water you could cut out the water in
terms of water could have easily been
cut out nobody would ever know he left
it but there's but he was showing that
it from the standpoint of water
a case in point from the standpoint of
water yeah as opposed to normally when
you see a desert scene what is from the
standpoint of sand
[Laughter]
technically what I meant
responded I mean is his political in
mistakes I see the to grant latch on to
the immigration issue and really mean it
to come out with a Muslim ban to talk
about the job-killing trade deals to not
jump when the media says jump over
Charlotte's ville to not apologize for
and chapter 2 is the Access Hollywood
tape he did not admit to a sexual
assault
long they're long they're lying and if
you remember that day and don't worry I
really I'm gonna get back okay I won't
let you I won't let great I may make you
play it again for me but on the access
hollywood tape the day it broke i was
out in the Breitbart offices and i
didn't say anything i walked in i didn't
know about it they told me about it and
said i thought he was joking
john khan looked up at me and said is it
over and I said well I'm smiling he
shows me well we walk into the other
room and every single station is playing
that over and over and over again and he
said I didn't say anything but my face
turned white and he thought it was over
and I admit I didn't I was just quiet I
was just watching watching watching and
then I started sending out some silly
tweets about it bye-bye
that evening watching the media and
they're tied to him overreaction to it
the same people who are always telling
his oh no we have to we have to hand out
condoms to kindergarteners and teach
them about fisting shocked about what
are you saying
the next day I gave a speech and I
debated James Carville in in Bakersfield
and there were like 5,000 just regular
farmers up in Bakersfield California and
I was pedal-to-the-metal defending Trump
on that Access Hollywood tape and the
audience was totally with me they just
thought screw you media and also by the
way it's illegal to release it it is
every bit as illegal as hacking DNC's
emails um and you say it's not sexual
assault because he clearly says you do
it and as you will see in Chapter two of
my book I see because I obsessively hate
watch MSNBC I started noticing because I
knew what he had said I'd watched them
play the tape they keep saying we're
playing the tape they edited that part
out they let you do it they let that the
blank consent action without the consent
that does change every time changer not
not the most polite tape in the world
shouldn't certainly does change from
listen to what he's saying it's much
like his formulation so we know he used
this formulation of citing something
that is axiomatically unacceptable to
describe a passion and enthusiasm
Yasim so I was axiomatically mean I know
it but he looks confused that's right
I'm just sitting here mounting
absolutely unacceptable I see um so when
he said my fans love me so much I could
shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue and they
won't and they won't leave me okay
he's not gonna shoot anyone on Fifth
Avenue but he's citing something extreme
he's doing the same thing in the Access
Hollywood tape saying celebrity culture
is so out of whack you can grab women by
the p-word they let you do it I mean
he's not even necessarily saying it with
approval he's saying this is nuts
proving a point by saying something that
is so ridiculously not plausible
formulation he yes so they lie about it
they take that part out and as they're
doing with the with the with Cavanaugh's
accuser I mean even on her description
very a drunken groping throwing on the
bed trying to take her clothes off
suddenly becomes I thought he was trying
to kill me go sorry I thought he might
inadvertently kill me so is a
manslaughter right so while we're
talking about helping Trump tapes let's
replay the Trump tape from yesterday
would you want to hear that yeah I do
Anthony and please notice the the
footage they use it really does drive
the point home yeah let's see if this is
yeah I just want to thank all of the
incredible men and women who have done
such a great job in helping with
Florence this is a tough hurricane one
of the wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water reminded me of the
Access Hollywood Dave was remember that
night when Trump cuz everybody's saying
he's got to say something he's got to
say something do you remember the tape
he cut in response to the access on tape
well I wish you could find that one
because it was like he was reading a
hostage note he didn't he did not want
to say anything he did not apologize um
and I thought I actually really admire
him for not apologizing for that I
admire him for being angry at even you
could tell he was being forced to say
anything
either because he was just speaking
honestly off-the-record to somebody it's
illegal I think a husband it to tape it
to record it and certainly to publish it
I didn't care that he said it didn't
bother me when you say he was speaking
honestly you mean he was speaking in a
way that was uncensored not honestly a
necessity loves to grab puss either way
he was whatever you speak he uncensored
and even if he was saying that because
let's be honest it looks a lot pretend
years and probably slept with a lot of
people I don't care but I think it it's
almost the reverse of honest I think he
is such a dork that he thinks this is
how guys talk in the locker room it's
like listening to a gay guy pretends not
to be gay and talk about a women woman's
boobs don't talk about her girlfriends
that way I showed stormy Daniels his
Yeti pubes he did and the end the
Playboy models or the Playboy I believe
them but anyway I don't care I'm not
saying this because oh if it were true I
would abandon all support I just want a
wall but I died I mean is there any part
of you that's jealous because you have
your gun to sleep with our great
president Trump he'll be a part of you
that's a little jealous that you'd like
to would you have a lover here with the
great president Trump only if he builds
the wall will sleep with you if you just
begin the wall if you start construction
on the wall okay so let's get okay okay
all right we can watch this see why it
reminded me this is Donald Trump's
response it in 2016 to the Access
Hollywood tape where he said grab it by
the [ __ ] take some audio there it is
you know what pretended to be someone
that I'm not I've said and done things I
regret
and the words released today on this
more than a decade old video are one of
them anyone who knows me knows these
words don't reflect Who I am I said it I
was wrong and I apologize I've traveled
the country talking about change for
America but my travels have also changed
me I've spent time with grieving mothers
who've lost their children laid off
workers whose jobs have gone to other
countries and people from all
walks of life who just want a better
future I have gotten to know the great
people of our country and I've been
humbled by the faith they placed in me I
pledged to be a better man tomorrow and
will never ever let you down let's be
honest we're living in the real world
this is nothing more than a distraction
from the important issues we're facing
today we are losing our jobs we're less
safe than we were eight years ago and
Washington is totally broken Hillary
Clinton and her kind have run our
country into the ground I've said some
foolish things but there's a big
difference between the words and actions
of other people Bill Clinton has
actually abused women and Hillary has
bullied attacked shamed and intimidated
his victims we will discuss this more in
the coming days see you at the debate on
Sunday I tell you that was a brilliant
good he did apologize but he handled it
well he didn't he didn't grovel right
there was no groveling other Republican
would have mentioned Bill Clinton no
other Republican you're right - about
the fact that he's reading and he ever
read you see necessarily angry to me
though he seemed like that was a he knew
that that was the right thing to do and
he and he brought up being humbled by
meeting people and I don't know I
thought that was a really good one no
IIIi take back the words of it I think
it was actually beautifully phrased but
no other Republican would have done that
to immediately go to his issues which is
what he's popular on to attack Hillary
and say these are just words they've
actually wrecked the country it was
great it's also absolutely manifestly
clear that he is just reading it and you
feel like there's a gun at his head okay
what tell me because there's no way that
he is real let's go back to the
hurricane clinic okay there is no way
he's not necessarily reading there's no
way that this phrase was written no
you're right your let's play I'll tell
you he's reading part of it but I'll
tell you where he jumps in and improv
could you do that yes I will okay he's
reading and I'll tell you where he
improv okay
reading go I just want to thank reading
the incredible men and women reading who
have done such a great job in helping
with Florence this is a tough hurricane
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of water employees give
us your take on the perspective of water
okay he was not doing that with the
Access Hollywood tape he was just
reading what was on the screen right
with this one I I kept noticing this in
his speeches I'd sit back and think man
I wish you were more articulate and then
and then I noticed that that people who
aren't me actually understand him better
than they understand like the
beautifully eloquent Ted Cruz and one of
my friends I feel like you're being
facetious no no no no no no one of my
friends I started talking to one of my
friends who's a big Union guy and she
told me no and I know and by the way
he's very very smart he's the most
articulate person I've ever met he said
Ann you know me I'm probably the most
articulate person you know all they
actually say that well no but he is
hyper articulate and and he said I'll be
talking to a group of Union guys I don't
think I've explained the deal so
beautifully and they're all looking at
me with blank expressions one guy will
turn to the other start grunting and
then they'll all start cheering the
grunts they do not understand me and
there's something about the way Trump
talks that it's almost like a dog
whistle some people understand this and
that's what he does when he when he does
the improv cuz they go like this they go
like this yeah I mean I guess it's
really wet and then he goes from the
perspective of water and they go oh yeah
cuz floods absolutely that's what that's
what cues in myself a lot a lot a lot
yes I see this is one thing you know
showing how I'm still trying to work
together in the era of Trump I've
advised some of my friends at the New
York Times that well for one thing if
they want to go after him go after him
for not building the wall Oh point one
point two I said I thought it would be a
fun thing to do just cuz I think it
would be funny to see you know you know
it's not gonna hurt him that much but
they say that I think they're like I
forget I saw an OE d thing on
the on c-span and the number of words
there are in the world it's like two
trillion English words okay but we only
use I forget what it was the most the
most people in any book will be like
700,000 and the most the average person
uses I'm making these numbers up and say
a hundred thousand with Trump I think
it's like 20 and you can do a computer
analysis to see how many because
everyone and I think that's part of the
repetition and part of always using the
same words this also reminds me just was
doing there with all this is stereo from
the resistance about how he has an
authoritarian personality it's like
Hitler it's a flashback to 70 years ago
he gets into office he's the exact
opposite of Anna Flores here
Tyrion personality he goes around
calling everything incredible he's
tremendous people get young on he's a
great guy so funny loves his people
tremendous tremendous right everybody's
tremendous everybody's incredible until
they were on you and then not a good guy
very bad guy very bad authoritarian to
to speak about other people you know
tremendous terrific didn't go around
saying Oh tremendous people here you
know think Hitler would have said like
read another article in failing New York
Times Laurie welcome you're on with the
N Coulter or Lonnie Lauren I saw a third
was Laurie - sorry Lonnie thanks for
taking my call and tweets almost every
other day about you know we don't have a
Department of Justice why doesn't he
fire oh great question it doesn't seem
to know he's president the case of Jeff
Sessions I don't want anyone to tell him
because I mean this is when he drives me
crazy you think that Trump yes um I mean
two out of three days I think he's the
Emperor God on the third day I want to
fly to Washington and hold his head
underwater until the bubbles stop and
when he attacks sessions that's one of
time sessions is the one member of the
administration who is keeping Trump's
promises on the immigration but he's
become so obsessed with Russia Russia is
so in his head and it's all nonsense and
no one cares outside of Washington and
and and newsrooms all he wants he wants
to turn the entire Department of Justice
over to a prosecute Hillary Loretta
Lynch Eric Holder James Comey look all
of that would be fun but if he really
wants to screw over Loretta Lynch and
and and Hillary Clinton build the wall
and go pedal to the metal on immigration
he is not doing any but only Jeff
Sessions is but Lonnie's point is
fantastic I mean it would be like having
the manager at Burger King instead of
just firing some useless burger flipper
constantly tweeting about this guy
doesn't know how to flip a burger well
they get rid of them